So, hello, everybody.
My name is Adrien Trauth, I'm a frontend engineer.
Our topic today is how to build advanced search
experiences with a custom query language.
First, I will focus on the use case.
I will explain what it is and the benefits
of introducing one in the search interface.
And then how to implement it in the code of
your advanced search.
And finally, the solution for your users to
make sure they are aware and how to write
their own queries.
So, let's get a bit more into the use case
and why is an advanced search necessary and
custom query language, improves the user experience?
And spending most of my day marking the lab
management tool and doing lab management is
about allowing the user to search for millions
of events and find the right one.
This is the search.
Since it's about traversing, you run a lot
of searches before finding the information.
The search needs to be efficient because you're
running a lot of things and using the tool
a very long time.
Also, because you need to find the right log
that will explain what's happening inside
of your infrastructure, your search has to
be precise or you will not find the needle
in the haystack.
They can be system logs to database event
to system logs, the data is not known.
So, you have to make yourself flexible enough
to search all kinds of different data.
And so, those are our requirements for the
search.
They're not really specific to log management.
But this is what we will be working with today.
And the common search interfaces match those
requirements.
So, basically word search, you find on a lot
of websites.
It's nice because it's simple and you can
get start in a few seconds.
It's really efficient.
You type a few keywords, and, in a few seconds,
you already have your first results.
But the limitation with that search is precision.
Because, for example, here, if I'm on the
phone, I'm looking for a blue chair, I have
no way to tell the system that I'm not looking
for either something that's blue or a chair.
And I'm looking for a chair that's specifically
blue.
So, you have no way to give the system what
your intent is.
And to give the context about what you're
searching for.
So, the way a lot of websites solve this is
that the sorry they introduce an advanced
search pattern.
And when you click on that pattern, you will
see a lot of different inputs and everything.
And what this gives to you is a lot more precision
because every input has its own intent.
If I select the color blue, all the results
are blue this time.
What you notice here with that pattern is
efficiency.
You went from a search where you could type
a few words and get results to a search where
you have to click around a lot and find out
which inputs are relevant to you.
And also, it makes this a lot less readable
because you have to look if you want to know
exactly what you're searching for, you have
to look at every input and the value of every
input.
And finally, it's not that flexible.
The way you set up the inputs defines the
ways that searchers search for something.
Here I put one price range, and if the searcher
wants to search across two price ranges, they
cannot do that.
As a developer, I know another way to search
for results.
That's query languages.
You send to, for example, a database or an
API some text that's going to return your
results.
The first query that you usually learn about
when you start, I don't know, when you're
a child, is natural language.
That's asking a question in English.
It's very flexible.
Because you can ask any question in English
and it's always making sense.
That's your own language.
The issue with natural language is that it's
not made for computers.
So, computers, they struggle with nuances.
And also, the range of questions you will
be able to ask is a lot bigger than the question
you can answer on your website.
And so, if you have Google or Facebook money,
it may be fine.
You may be able to solve that problem.
But for your own tool and website, it's probably
a little bit overkill.
The second query language that I encountered
was SQL.
So, that's a query language for databases.
It's very powerful because it allows you to
query any kind of structure data.
Also, it has great support.
You have a lot of databases supporting it
and if you want to implement it, you basically
send the search through the server to the
database.
You have nothing more to do.
But this is for us, it's not really good for
our use case because you have to know how
the data is stored to be able to query it,
and that's not something we want our users
to care about.
And it's a bit too complex.
And it's not what we want there.
And so, one of the systems that tries to solve
this is GraphQL.
Since it's an abstraction of a data storage,
it's a bit better because you don't have to
care about how the data is stored.
And what's really nice also is that you can
define easily what kind of output you want
for your data.
But it's still very much targeted to APIs.
So, for example, if you see that query here
and you would it's really nice if you want
to send it over HTTP, or if you write it in
your code.
But if you want a user to write that query,
it's a bit long, it's a bit verbose.
So, that's not really what we want here.
So, since we've not been about to able to
form anything that matches our requirements,
since I'm a developer, I made my own query
language.
I found companies that did that.
There's GQL, allows you to search through
your tasks and issues.
There are some tools, they have their own
way to create data.
And data that is there is another team that
made its own query language to the query data
visualizations.
And so, we are two different teams finding
the same way to solve problems.
So, one of the benefits of having your own
custom query language.
First, it's as high level as you want.
So, you are able to decide what you want your
users to care about or not.
So, for example, if you want your user to
be able to define the output format, like
in GraphQL, you can include that in your language.
But you want to make it a bit more simple,
you just choose that and do your own thing.
It's also very specific to our use case.
So, you can make sure that every word that
the user types is relevant to your demand
and express what the user is looking for and
there's not technical getting in the way.
And finally, since it's high level and user
specific, it's readable.
The only in the query are about the domain
and not technical.
So, this seems to be a good solution for our
use case here.
So, to be and it's probably not perfect, but
we'll get into the limitations a bit later.
Now that I know that I want to make my own
query language, I have to define it.
And so, a language definition is called a
grammar.
And so, that's going to be the set of rules
that define what valid search is and the meaning
of each word in my valid search.
Two things you should care about when writing
your grammar is you have to make it flexible
for the user to write any kind of different
queries.
And make sure your most important concepts,
the first thing the user is going to look
for is the first thing they have to write
so that they can benefit from your query language
very fast.
Let's give you a quick example to give you
a better idea of what a grammar is.
So, that's my simplified English grammar.
Obviously, we're not going to get into all
the rules of English now.
But if I were to define grammar for English,
the first rule is a sentence is a set of words
separated by spaces.
And if I use that rule, I'm going to be allowed
to say, well, I have three words in this sentence.
I like meatballs.
And then I can use a second rule which would
say that the first word is the subject, the
second is the verb and the third is the object
to say that, oh, I is my subject, like is
my verb and meatballs is the object.
By defining the rules, you can extract words
and the context of the words and find the
meaning of the sentence.
And we know that we and we can apply that
to my example, which is still here.
If I were to write a grammar for my search
language, I would be able to define a set
of rules that say, for example, a search query
for my furniture would be furniture, separated.
And there is the type of the furniture and
then brackets and inside the brackets there's
a list of attributes I care about for this
furniture.
By using that, I can say, hey, I'm looking
for a chair and a couch.
And the chair is blue.
And the couch has the attribute, green.
And if I want to go even further, I can say,
well, actually in my attributes, every attribute
that starts with a hashtag will be a color,
and every attribute that ends with a currency
will be a price.
So, that's how you get into writing your own
query.
And once you have defined all those rules,
you can once you have defined your grammar
the next step is actually to implement it
in the code of your search.
And so, that's making the computer understand
the set queries.
So, the goal here is to get from a string
it an object that will be easier for my code
and contain all the context that was extracted
from the string.
And then once I have an object that's very
simple, I can use it anywhere.
If I want to create databases, if I want to
extract information for the user or anything
like that.
Once you have an object, you're pretty much
on all the jobs.
So, to go from the string to the object is
actually called parsing.
And so, parsing will say, well, actually,
from that query I extract that one word is
"Chair."
And since I have grammar rules, chair is not
a color, it's the first word.
It's not inside brackets.
It's the type.
That's what parsing is.
The first thing I think about when I want
to extract information from the string is
to try to raise the regular expression.
Regular expressions are really efficient when
you are extracting information from emails
or telephones.
So, when you know the number of things you
want to extract from the query, it's really
good.
But when you don't know, your expression gets
really complex.
And also, it's hard to extract the element
you extracted.
It's easy to extract, for example, the chair.
But if I want to extract it's a furniture
type, that's more complex.
And I found this really good code on StackOverflow
that says if you write to regular expression,
you go with a cup of coffee, then you come
back, and you have no idea what you just wrote.
Maybe a regular expression is not the tool
for you.
So, I think that's explaining really why this
is not good for our use case here.
So, the other way to extract from a string
is to generate from the language.
From the grammar I just explain in English,
I can actually generate a parser from that.
And the way to do that is to write the grammar
in another grammar.
So, there is actually a way to write grammars
and there are rules to write grammars.
And so, the one we'll be using today is the
passing expression grammar.
I found it to be one of the most readable
ones, PEG.
How does that work in practice?
It seems hard now.
That's a grammar rule.
A grammar rule is made of first the name of
the rule and then your parsing expression.
So, your parsing expression will define the
input you want to match.
And the output you want to return from that
match.
And so, here for our type rule, I'm matching
a range of characters repeating any number
of times.
And then I'm using that much results which
you will be an array of characters which is
the full string of the furniture type.
It looks like a regular expression, right?
Yes, but what is really nice with this way
of writing different rules is that it's really
easy to combine them.
So, here, for example, if I want to extract
my simple character match, it's actually adjusting
the new rule and using that new rule in my
furniture type rule.
And what I see is really good about this is
that it's really easy to reuse some and in
the other ones.
And also, it makes your numbers definition
a lot more readable.
Because here I can read that my furniture
type would be a set of characters and I don't
have to care about one type of character or
not.
That's different rule.
So, it allows you to write really complex
rules in a very simple way.
So, another way to combine different rules
is to put them in sequence.
So, here, if I have to define a price, I just
need to define first what the number is.
And then what a currency is.
So, number will be an integer.
And pound, Euro, anything you would want to.
And from that sequence of characters, my parser
will try to match both.
If only one of them matches, it's just going
to fail.
And once I have matched both those rules,
I'm going to be able to use both match results
which I call here amount and currency.
And I will be able to combine both those match
results actually inside the brackets.
That's valid JavaScript.
And to define a new match result for price,
which is really a combination of the two others.
And a final way you can combine didn't rules
is to put them separated by slashes.
And then you will be what that will do is
that this is this object from the options.
So, if I define an attribute as a price or
a color, what the parser will do here is going
to be to try to match price.
And if that succeeds, I'm going to return
the same match result as for the price.
If that fails, I'm going to go to the next
one and match the color and et cetera and
et cetera.
And once you have that way of writing different
rules and to combine them in didn't ways,
I can actually start defining my full grammar
for my furniture store.
And here so, I said in any grammar, as I explained
in English, the furniture will be a type,
brackets and any number of attributes.
What I think is really amazing here is exactly
what I'm reading in the code.
That's valid code.
I wrote the full query grammar to make sure
it's something that makes sense.
And so, here if you read the first, it's defining
what a furniture is.
And I'm defining it as a furniture type and
then a list of attributes.
And if I want to see what a list of attributes
is, I can just go to the last line and see,
well, a list of attributes is just one opening
bracket, any number of attributes, and one
closing bracket.
And so, what I think what I love about this
is that I can every rule is actually quite
simple.
And you can go from very simple rules to a
full query language in a way that's really
testable.
Really easy to improve on, really easy to
extend.
That's good that's really readable and really
simple.
And once you've done that, once of your full
query language or your rules defined, you
just have to run it.
And that's going to generate a parser that
will that you will able to import in your
code.
So, I'm just running it through the command
line.
you can use the results in Webpack loader
if you want to make it automatic.
And now that I'm generating my parser, I'm
just importing it.
Running my queries through it and I'm going
to be able to have the exact object I was
looking for.
So, I'm able to parse my different queries.
I can just use that in my search.
Hopefully type chair, hashtag blue.
And I'm only going to have a blue chair.
I used to have my keyword search that would
return either chair or things that were blue.
There was a blue table in the results.
Now the query language provides intent.
Now I can say that the color is applied to
chair.
And blue is actually a color.
I can implement it in my sorry.
It's matching all my requirements.
So, I have the intent, so, that's precise.
It's also efficient because I just have to
do a few key strokes to get the results.
And it's readable, I have the full search
in my query.
And it's flexible.
I can have any number of attributes.
Any number of furnitures.
Flexible is actually up to you when you design
your search language.
It's a balance to find.
So, did we solve the search problem forever?
Well, not really.
Because I think a custom query language comes
with one big limitation, and that's user onboarding.
Because know that you have a language that
is valid or not.
The first experience you can give to your
user is that before they would type anything
and that would always work.
But now what they can do is the first search
they type is not valid and you won't be able
to parse it and they won't get any results.
And that's really frustrating for your users.
So, you need to teach them two things before
they are able to write their own queries.
And the first thing is the grammar.
What is a valid query?
And the possible attribute.
You want to tell them, you can search for
a chair, a coat, anything you want.
You need to tell them what values they can
put inside of the queries.
The first thing you need to do is add documentation.
That's really important.
You always need documentation.
And to give quick access to the documentation.
But that's not enough because to make them
want to go to the documentation you need to
give them a few valid searches, so they know
that, oh, that's really useful.
I want to learn more about that.
And so, one way that's worked for us is to
have a playground, like an advanced search.
We are adding back some inputs.
But the difference is this time you are not
using the inputs to make queries to the back
end.
You're using inputs to modify the search bar
and make a valid search inside your search
bar.
So, let's see how that would look.
Yeah.
So, here I select chair, and adding chair
to my queries and then blue.
And once you have a valid send, the user will
be able to by himself to improve upon it and
start typing his own search queries.
Because it's stitching by example.
And that's really good.
You want to show him what it looks like and
show him, oh, it's really simple.
I can do it myself now.
It's progressive because you start doing it,
and when you feel ready, you can start modifying
your search.
And if you feel like you're even more ready,
you can sorry you can write your own search
and hide their playground.
You cannot use it anymore.
And it adapts to the user.
Because if they want to learn more about it,
they can type things.
But they never want to run it because they
only come on the website once.
They can click the inputs and never care about
the query language.
It's really not an advanced search because
you don't need to use the chat box anymore.
You can use them or not.
You don't have to have all the attributes.
You can add them in the documentation.
And since the state is synchronized with the
search bar, you don't need to read the state
of every selected patch, so it's still very
readable.
And since I have a parser, it's easy to implement
because I know how to extract information
from my query to select the field.
And I need to click to add the value to my
query and to print it again.
And that's kind of easy to implement because
think object is simple.
So, I just need to push a value inside the
object.
And then to define a print function.
And the print function is actually it's great
because all the context is in the object.
So, it's really easy to go from all the context
back to a string.
So here, for example, I say furniture will
be a furniture name and the print value of
all the attributes.
And for attributes, it seems in the attribute
name it contains a lot of context too.
I can say, well, if it's a color, you print
it as a hashtag and the attribute value.
We have a way to generate this, but if you're
writing it by yourself, it's actually fairly
straightforward.
And a few things you can add is error reporting.
Telling the user, why is such queries not
valid?
Syntax highlight if you want to have the information.
And autocomplete showing what values they
can type.
Set of colors or chair when they start typing
the query.
So, autocomplete is really efficient.
So, the benefits of having some query language
is it's efficient, it's precise, it's readable
and it's flexible.
The drawback is that you are teaching your
users and it becomes crucial and you have
to care about that a lot more than with a
simple keyword search.
So, good use cases for custom query language
would be a tool that's used repeatedly.
If you have a tool that's spent a lot of time
on, being efficient becomes a lot more important.
Also, sharing.
Because it's always nicer to share a small
search that's readable than a full object
when it's inexact.
And if you want to have integrations like
APIs or integrate results, it's nice for the
developers to be able to type the query, copy
and paste it in the HTTP request and that's
just going to work.
Thank you for listening.
If you have any questions [ Applause ]